[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of the demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the pr consultant alex dean they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the eye describes the uk as being on red
alert after the news that half of the
first identified cases of the omicron
variant
turned out to be in people who'd had two
doses of the vaccine
according to the guardian a leading
group of scientists has told the
government there's no time for further
research on the new variant so they must
decide now what they want to do about it
amid what the financial times calls
mixed messages from the government a
leading hospitality body reports
christmas party bookings are currently
30 lower than anticipated for this time
of year
the mail carries boris johnson's pledge
to hold accountable the people who
failed to prevent the abuse and death of
six-year-old arthur lobinjo hughes
on that same story the express pleads
never let evil stepmom taste freedom
again
the times understands the chancellor
rishi sunak will either cut income tax
by 2p in the pound or reduce a vat
before the next election
the northern echo reports that more than
80 army soldiers have been deployed to
the northeast to help people who are
still without power after storm
irwin the telegraph says that pestering
and making lewd comments to women in the
street could be outlawed in the wake of
sarah everard's murder
the mirror his strictly come dancing
judge craig revel hallwood has found
himself in a spot of bother after
appearing in an advert something which
violates rules for bbc on-screen talent
and the star speaks to short statured
actors who say their parts as dwarves in
christmas pantos have been taken by
actors of average height
joining me tonight polly mckenzie and
alex dean to run us through the papers
let's start with the eye
and they're looking at the fact that
half the first wave of omicron cases
were people who were double vaccinated
alex
yeah worth bearing in mind it's still a
very small sample
size so far with under 200 cases but
nevertheless this is desperately bad
news in an environment in which for a
long time now we have been told and
believed that vaccines are the way out
of this situation and back to normality
if as this
seems to suggest we are going to
have new variants which are
impervious to or at least somewhat
able to penetrate the protection of
vaccines then we're going to have to
find a new way
to deal with coronavirus and its
variants one of which is very likely to
be learning to live with it and
accepting a certain element of risk in
life after all we cannot go on with
round after round of lockdown
restriction boosters and so forth
forever can we
polly still so much that we don't know
about omicron though isn't there
there absolutely is and i think you know
it still remains absolutely the case
that it is much better to be vaccinated
than not vaccinated
that you know omicron does have all of
these mutations and it's possible that
it may uh have some ability to you know
to you know infect and cause serious
illness among among people who are
double jabbed as existing variants can
but that doesn't mean
there's no point getting vaccinated
doesn't mean there's no point getting a
booster and so yeah of course whilst
alex is right of course that doesn't
mean i think it's really important that
we don't uh give any suggestion that
vaccines don't remain absolutely our
best weapon against this and whilst it
will take time it's perfectly possible
that scientists will be able to adapt
the vaccine if there is some of that
kind of vaccine penetration vaccine
breakthrough
but it is still a really uncertain and
difficult time and the government is put
in a difficult situation because of
course
we for months have been thinking that we
have broken the back of this still you
know far more deaths and is comfortable
still a lot a lot of cases and
around the world a huge amount of
suffering but nevertheless it's not as
bad as it was because of that wall of
protection that we had built
if this turns out to be as serious as it
could be
i think that's really going to affect
the next few months um but we can all
continue to wait for that data to come
out and hope that in fact
um it's not as bad as it looks
sure i didn't mean to suggest any sort
of skepticism about vaccines i'm double
jab myself and i'll take my uh booster
when i can but i would say um that
well two things we have broken uh one
thing we've broken the link currently
between
infection and hospitalization and
infection and death and we've yet to see
while people have got coronavirus uh
this new variant whilst having been
double jabbed we've yet to see how
harmful to them it is and if it is less
harmful as facts as
viruses sometimes are they become more
virulent but less harmful to people then
that will be really good news despite
the fact that people can get it um
whilst they've been uh vaccinated but of
course i accept what polly says i don't
mean to suggest we shouldn't be getting
vaccinated we should but my point is we
are going nevertheless to have to accept
that we're going to have new infections
in society i think over time that
we're going to have people being
diagnosed with coronavirus even though
they've been vaccinated and we're going
to get to a point in society where we
accept a certain amount of risk from
coronavirus in the same way that we
accept a certain amount of risk in every
other aspect of life
yes and polly you were saying that that
there's still so much that we don't know
and that the data has to be collected
but according to the guardian they're
saying that ministers have been warned
that we can't wait for new research on
the omicron variant we must act now to
prevent a potentially very significant
wave of infections that risk
overwhelming the nhs so they're saying
we can't wait for the data
i think it's it's a sort of challenge in
pandemic response and what we have
learned over the last nearly two years
is as i think chris whittie put it you
should always act a bit earlier and a
bit more aggressively than you want to
if you want to suppress a wave
and of course we as alex says we we
don't know this might be less dangerous
as a variant it might be more dangerous
it might be more virulent it might be
less but you know
we don't know the problem is if it's the
worst case scenario and we have waited
then that's when it causes immense
difficulty to the nhs which is you know
trying desperately to catch up with this
huge backlog
of of unmet need of uh you know of
operations of cancer diagnosis
and if we allow covert infections to
increase
dramatically and that leads to a wave of
hospitalizations
whether those lead to deaths or not
nevertheless it occupies hospitals which
are trying to deal with this other very
serious disease burden which of course
can cause deaths as well so it you know
balancing
what our nhs needs is really difficult
and and i think it's always a danger for
politicians and we saw it with i think
that you know the bulk purchasing of
tamiflu when you know several years ago
we thought there was going to be a
flu epidemic
if it doesn't go wrong you look like
you've overreacted and you've wasted
money and that's the thing there's no
question if they if they do tighten
restrictions now
and then it turns out that as the data
comes from omicron actually it's it's
not as bad as we'd feared then you know
they will be attacked the government
before having overreacted from those
people who are affected by that lockdown
the question is what's the what's the
balance of risks and what the guardian
is suggesting that not surprisingly the
scientists are on the side of saying
let's not run the risk that this is
awful and it gets out of control before
we have the chance to take uh
prophylactic measures alex are you
worried by the the guardian reporting
that uh privately the government is
being urged by their own scientific
advisers to tell people where possible
to work from home until christmas
yes and that's of course contrary to the
government's current position so it
would be a significant shift change in
um the government's position on advice
to uh people and i think too it's worth
bearing in mind what the ramifications
of steps like that would be we've
already seen remarkable harm done to our
retail leisure travel sectors and this
isn't just uh lives against money it's
lives against lives if you are working
in those sectors you're made
redundant the harm to your life the harm
to your quality of life is very
significant one of our big things we've
just done is this remarkable achievement
of a booster program uh
millions of people receiving their
booster uh jab over a very short period
of time i was talking to somebody in a
small surgery where they are cranking
out a thousand a day and that was not a
big
multi-center a big small gp surgery but
guess what when they're doing that
they're not doing anything else and so
when i say it's lives against lives
there are other conditions you might be
detecting uh you might be seeking to
assist people with or in a case of a
hospital you might be treating or doing
an operation
for that you're not because we are um
doing what we're doing now so what
polly's saying is right about balance
but gosh i there is a real risk on the
overreaction it's not all just upside
and can't be too careful in fact there
are significant risks and human harm uh
to overdoing this and that's why polly's
point about balance rather than just
saying precautionary principle you know
if it says one life it's worth it press
the button now that's not always correct
look at the telegraph
and this story about plans to make
public sexual harassment an offense um
some people might think that it already
was polly
yeah i mean uh harassing women uh is uh
is an offense you know violence is an
offense but simply catcalling or
uh
women in the street it's not there's
been a review of the law here partly as
a result of um campaigns to make
misogyny
itself a hate crime
uh which the prime minister dismissed by
making a sort of slightly uncomfortable
and yet probably true comment that you
couldn't possibly do that because
there's just so much of it it would
overwhelm the police um
this is a funny sort of way to use the
criminal law because you know those of
us who have been and i think it's pretty
much every woman i know been
called out in the street or told to
smile or you know
cheered at when you're out for a run
nobody is going to get prosecuted for
this stuff and yet what it does is it it
sets a norm that we as a society condemn
this behavior i think there are still
men out there who think that it lifts a
girl or a woman's day to be you know
called out in the street and this is an
opportunity for you know women to say it
really really doesn't it's awful and it
should stop
alex is it um
about
about time
it's another piece with what
government's doing more broadly if you
think about the
reform of laws
so the
criminalization of the
malicious sharing of intimate images
is another example of where we are
seeking to protect
women in society from this kind of abuse
i think it's quite right that this
happens perhaps beyond time i mean one
does think about the fact this is going
to depend on um being able to prove that
the person committing the offense
intended to commit at the offense
meaning it's our cause harassment alarm
or distress to the victim which is
already an offence but it certainly
underscores and will point out to people
this kind of behavior
is wrong it may be difficult i think in
the end in some cases to obtain a
successful prosecution but the law being
on the statute book could have a
sanitary effect in behavior which has
gone on too long and is
very unpleasant for the victims who
suffer it alex and polly thank you very
much and uh paulie and alex will be
staying with us for the next hour to
discuss tonight's news and tomorrow's
headlines
let's take a look at the weather for you
quickly
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it'll be cold and windy this weekend
with some blustery and wintry showers
and things are set to turn very
unsettled next week overnight rain will
clear eastern parts of england during
saturday morning but brisk northwesterly
winds will introduce colder air and
blustery showers some of the showers
will be heavy with hail thunder and even
some snow mainly over the hills there'll
be some bright or sunny spells but it
will feel very cold with a significant
wind chill in the strong and gusty winds
the showers will merge into longer
spells of rain sleet and hill snow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Music]
i wanted to retrain as an engineer
though starting again in the mid 30s is
hard
but i never gave up
amazon supported me
now i'm getting hands-on experience
and they're even paying for my new
qualification
with my amazon apprenticeship i can
focus on both learning
and making my dreams a reality
[Music]
born in roma
the fragrances by valentino
[Music]
this christmas nothing's stopping us so
gather round this tesco finest turkey
imagine me and you
i do
i think about you day and night it's
only right not all hybrids
are born equal
toyota chr self-charging hybrid
hello hybrid happiness
bring imagination to life
sophology feel at home on a sofa you
love
introducing roxy's new free tv music app
unlimited music videos with 70 million
music releases search the latest and the
greatest from every genre and decade
plus hundreds of exclusive music
channels for you to sit back and enjoy
plus music games and even karaoke try
roxy premium and get a free roxy karaoke
mic
get roxy free on the sky q apps rail for
free on fire tv google tv and android tv
see roxy.tv
let's change water
so it flows forever
energy so it powers our life sustainably
and mobility so cities become
playgrounds
let's change the way we feed the world
designed to live with nature
and create factories that make the
future better
this is where we can change it all
neo
made to change
[Music]
create the extraordinary alien and alien
goddess the new perfume mugler
all i ever wanted
venom let that be carnage available now
in sky store premiere
within 20 years there will be not a
community untouched by the aids epidemic
i felt like i was the walking dead we
lived through hiv don't you remember
[Music]
truth is i hate christmas
it's 11 o'clock this is sky news's
extended news review and press preview
our top story a new covered crackdown in
ireland nightclubs are closed bars will
have table service only and numbers at
all events are restricted until january
every time we have faced a new challenge
we have pulled together as a nation and
done what was needed
i'm asking all us all to do that again
prime minister should people go ahead
with christmas party plans
will you be having a christmas party
prime minister
but the prime minister gives a thumbs up
to festive celebrations going ahead in
the uk
the father of arthur la bincho hughes
and his partner emma tustin have been
sentenced to a total of 50 years in jail
over his killing
cold angry and feeling abandoned nearly
10 000 people are still without power a
week after storm armor
close to disaster a report into disorder
at the euro 2020 final at wembley finds
ticketless fans nearly led to deaths
the entire coaching staff at yorkshire
county cricket leave the club in the
wake of the azim rafiq racism round
over the next hour we'll be discussing
today's news with our reviewers the
director of the demos think tank polly
mckenzie and the pr consultant alex dean
and later we'll have a full run through
of tomorrow's front pages
[Music]
good evening keep calm and carrying on
with christmas that was the message from
government today despite new evidence of
the rise of the new coveted variant the
first official analysis of omicron cases
in the uk found that more than half of
the people infected had been double
jabbed the prime minister insisted that
christmas should go ahead as normally as
possible but in the last few minutes
it's been confirmed that omicron cases
rose threefold today and tonight the
republic of ireland has introduced tough
new restrictions
over concerns about rising cases of
covet there including shutting all
nightclubs until january and returning
to table service only in bars
over the next hour we'll bring you
tonight's headlines tomorrow's front
pages and the views of our paper
reviewers polly mckenzie and alex dean
but first laura bundock has tonight's
main report
jab by jab the rollout ramps up and
boosters now brought forward the nhs
says the new variant has created a new
national mission
we've certainly seen more coming forward
for their boosters which is great but
even people who haven't yet taken up the
vaccine or
still need their second dose so we're
just seeing lots coming through people
booking appointments walking in as well
you can walk in seven days a week so
it's certainly increased
but the drive to deliver more doses
comes at a cost gp is now given
permission to postpone routine care and
check